today we got ourselves a package
space force dollars uh i got interested
in these when i
saw an ad on youtube that was
advertising
space force two dollar bills and they
swore it was legal tinder dude they
swore was legal
for 10 space force dollars you know how
much it cost a hundred dollars for ten
dollars here it is ladies and gentlemen
the space force two dollar bill there's
no way
anyone accepts this now i just want to
jump in here because you might be
wondering well
is it legal is this a legal bill and the
answer is
i i don't know according to the the
private company who did this this is not
the government who printed this
this is a regular two dollar bill that a
private company has like
colorized on top of it with some
non-destructive
film or something like that i don't
really understand it but that has to
have its limitations right like this
just
looks ridiculous and i wanna know will
people actually
accept it we're gonna go to a bunch of
fast food restaurants and uh
check who has been bought out by the
chinese and who's still american
we'll order something from uh their
dollar menu try to pay with the two
dollar bill
we'll see who does it who accepts it and
who doesn't i'm
excited i don't think anyone if i had to
guess
i'll try about five places today i doubt
anyone will accept it
instead i think we're gonna find out
that the 100 i spent was a complete
waste of time
and uh i have gotten scammed oh we got a
wendy's here
i'll just take a small frosty please
61. hi do you guys take space force
dollars
they told me it was legal legal tender
genuine yeah
donald told me it was real they like
colorized the two dollar bill
i mean i guess we can we just don't get
a lot of two dollar bills around there
no worries thanks
wendy's 10 out of 10 patriotic confirmed
baby
i am totally shocked that felt too easy
hey i'm joining space force that's it
that's all there is to it up next we
have mcdonald's
i think handing him the trump thing got
him last time i like if i had to think
psychologically i think that overloaded
him
you don't get handed a uh certificate of
authenticity from donald trump very
often
so very interesting hi do you guys
accept the uh
space force two dollar bill
hold on sure oh boy hey
by the way if you need it i got a
certificate of authenticity
here
i think he likes this
donald's to be very happy thank you
this is not going i thought i thought
nobody would accept this
i saw someone here would you like would
you like space force dollars
what i've got two dollar bill in space
force dollars
seriously you know what it is it's a
type of two dollar bill
oh okay cool do you want it yeah it's a
real money
you just have to show them this here
show them this thank that yeah
absolutely thank you
god bless you save in america one space
horse dollar at a time
i gotta be honest driving home i felt
conflicted on the one hand
i was shocked that people accepted the
money
on the other hand i wondered how much my
own persuasion
played into that like i wondered could i
have just taken monopoly money and just
been like hey take it take it
hey and hand him some stupid you know
fake certificate of authenticity because
again
this is not like from the president
right they just literally have
donald trump on their little thing that
they send with it
and it says 45th president of the united
states which
sure is true but it it implies
that this is like some presidential bill
which it's not
and so i wondered how much that had to
do with it so i decided to call around
instead and kind of
remove that personal element remove this
from the equation as like a way to
persuade them and really just make it
about you know does it make sense to
accept a space force two dollar bill
do you guys accept uh the new space
force
two dollar bill and then the currency
that is usually tendered
right yeah but it's got it's the new
space force
like kind of logo i know some people
accept it
some people don't like donald trump
i think probably would accept it but um
given that there's
you know the new presidency that's all
been kind of called into question you
know
you know i don't know if joe biden all
right give me one moment let me source
okay cool you said it's space force
yeah it's the new space force two dollar
bill it's printed by the merrick mint
they're a private mint
like like i think if trump got elected
again it'd probably be legal tinder but
now i'm not so sure with joe biden so
i'm trying to spend i spent a lot of
money on these two dollar bills because
i thought they might be worth something
but
now i'm trying to spin them before biden
gets into office you know how he is with
like china and you know shijo ping and
i i get you i'm just trying to figure
out if we accept it you should you
should see it they've got like a
they've got like a spaceship on it
they've got like a rocket going to the
moon
um it's pretty cool bill i think i think
pizza hut would be
happy to happy to accept it all right so
she's saying we only accept the regular
recognized belt you do not accept
the united states space force two dollar
bill
she what she says to me is the regular
recognizable but i'm trying to explain
to her what it said it has a
spaceship on it it's got a spaceship on
it it's uh it's got a satellite
uh i don't know how else to describe it
as long as pizza hut spent it probably
before joe biden got into office i think
it'd probably be fine but
um i am a little bit worried that this
this currency will be useless
after you know the the socialist gets in
the white house i'm a little bit worried
about that
what i do suggest though okay
you can when you get to the store see if
they accept it at the store
but you're saying that they probably
won't though is what you're doing
because i don't want to drive down there
with all my
i've got like a duffel bag of spaces
and there shouldn't be a reason why they
would not accept it because
if it's printed to be used in the
country then you could be unpatriotic
i feel like that would be almost
unpatriotic it is the united states
space force unless like
the name has changed from the space
force to something i wouldn't say if
it's it's a part of patriotic or not
it's it's whether or not they know
it that's just it because if the
knowledge isn't there
then the experience is going to be there
as well
right yeah if the ignorance is there i
think they wouldn't take it but well
okay
i'll drive right into the store i mean
if that's what it takes to get this the
space force dollars off my hands
yeah that should make sure that that's
it okay great thank you all righty
thank you bye all right so this is going
to be a bit of a different test guys
this is going to be a starbucks chat
thing because so far we've gone in
person
we got him we called pizza hut we got
him now i want to know will starbucks
do it so i'm asking them a question
starbucks
accepting space force two dollar bill
question of patriotism first name ben
last name dover looks like we got dagger
okay hi dagger d does starbucks
currently accept space force
dollars maybe we should attach like a
picture of the space force dollar
i've attached the currency in question i
heard you guys were having a war with
christmas but i'm sure howard feels
differently about space force
ben i appreciate that you're trying to
confirm if we accept space force two
dollars
i'm gonna start attaching more files i
think
should i hit them with the certificate
of authority no one's been able
to resist the certificate of authority
guys
i don't have that information available
but i will be happy to find any updates
for you
well it seems like a simple question
of patriotism to be honest
i understand that the socialists
think donnie i sound so unhinged right
now
donnie is out of office but we've got
one month i think
space force bills should be allowed
through let's pull him into this i think
space force bills should be allowed
through
at least the end of donald's presidency
don't you and then let's hit him with
the certificate of authenticity
here we go we hit him with a certificate
of authenticity
at this time what i can do is share your
thoughts with the team in charge
this guy's useless also i would invite
you to post your idea
at ideas.starbucks.com most of the ideas
posted here have already come to
fruition
i'm not suggesting anything though
simply ask
if i bring in my two dollar base
force bill if they will give
me my grande you're more than welcome to
try ben
at this time there is no restriction are
any updates about
accepting this type of currency thank
you dagger d i
will be sure to note among my
fellow patriots that starbucks hasn't
sold
out to china just yet so to recap
i think starbucks was probably the worst
least likely to accept
but in this case i guess least likely to
accept does not necessarily mean bad
maybe more like
diligent wow so this is a weird twist i
was about to finish this video
and i teased it on social media and
somebody from within the business
reached out to me saying that they'd
love to share some
insider tips so this is my call with him
we learned how much money they're making
here's that talk as a little capstone to
this goofy video
do you see that yep yeah that's you guys
i yup we made that ad
that's 100 percent we actually i have
like the amount of like screenshots of a
cutout
of trump that i have is like hilarious
so how much money are you making with
this i mean i i've gotta
i never fall for ants i never gotta
understand you gotta understand you're
the first person who got me
i never fall for this stuff i saw it i
said it's too good they win
the marketers finally win how so yeah
what are we talking about here okay
they're good there you go it is good
so like so the cost of goods
for that bill so for us to get the bill
package it ship it out to you like
that's two dollars
uh specific bill uh for um for us
in particular it's in the seven dollar
range so for
others it could be anywhere
from like 9 12 or like whatever like
relationship you have with the
manufacturer but if you buy directly
from
them directly they'll sell to you for
about i think
about 15 bucks oh so but you guys have a
wholesale
deal they're actually just drop shipping
so we're shipping directly from the
manufacturer so it's not even wholesale
dang dude i've been telling people drop
shipping doesn't work okay
how much you making with this business
here brian so like just make it clear
i'm an employee of the business
we're hitting the uh about like 7.5 mill
in revenue
hang on brian that can't all be profit
but i do know
a large maybe larger profit margin than
people think if you're getting it for
seven bucks
it is a pretty high version you guys
charged me a freaking grip for this i'm
insulted
yes i had to pay like 20 bucks for that
obviously this has to be your best year
it being the election and everything and
does it kind of dry up after this i
guess
or do you switch to selling biden merch
i mean does biden merch sell
so so what's funny is that we tried
selling like life-leaning stuff multiple
times
and it flops like my boss when he was
right did for hillary completely flops
they don't give
two smacks about like hillary or like
democrat party whatever
but the minute we go conservative it
just
they just throw money at it it's wild
like for the biden and um like we have
our own buying bills
we we tried you know putting it through
facebook ads it's just
completely waste of money and you're
like all right we try like is it just
that it's trump or is it that it's like
a
leaning right-leaning thing i honestly i
think it's just like more of like a
i think just when it comes to online and
selling i think it's just like
like a like conservatives just in
general like i assume they just have
more money and
and like they're more passionate about
you know like trump
and like and like in their beliefs so
like it's really easy to sell that
patriotism to them
our next hottest drop is trump's still
our president that's our
we made a bill like him like fighting
back so he's like still our president
oh my gosh yeah hold on i'll show you
real quick
oh my gosh dude these are outrageous
these
are outrageous all right man well uh i'm
gonna leave it at that this video is not
sponsored so
not sponsored so i don't want to do a
whole
you know pitch fest but uh it's a
goofy gift guys goofy gift for the fam
some you guys a crazy uncle at
thanksgiving you want to make happy hey
still my president two dollar bill may
be just the thing
anyways guys um i'll see you next time
thanks and don't forget to smash like
and subscribe thank you